it's thursday in july fourteenth i'm
justin all the cool people have left the
office to go hunt pokemon and they
didn't invite me so i guess i'm going to
do the news today nintendo revealed a
new console today with a launch light up
of 30 games it's called the nes and it
was originally released in the 1980s
hold on what this isn't a joke the
official NES classic edition will launch
on November 11 and it's a smaller
version of the original nintendo
entertainment system the classic edition
will cost sixty dollars and it plugs
directly into your TV using an included
hdmi cable 30 games will be bundled with
the system including classics like super
mario brothers The Legend of Zelda and
Metroid like their virtual console
counterparts each game will support
suspend points allowing you to pick up
where you left off if you need to step
away for any reason also in the package
is one nes controller featuring a design
modeled after the original nes game pad
extra controllers will retail for ten
dollars but the classic edition or any
SCE or neski as we will all fondly call
it in the future will also support the
wii and wii u's classic controller and
classic controller pro if you love
playing online multiplayer shooters but
you hate playing with other people star
wars battlefront has just the answer for
you the developer announced new details
about an offline multiplayer mode as
well as new details about the Death Star
expansion the offline mode is called
skirmish and it'll be available starting
july 20th according to lead designer
Dennis bramble it offers players the
option to play offline against bots in a
solo mission or with a friend using
co-op split screen on console only there
will be two difficulty options for the
offline mode which is available for
walcker assault and fighter squadron in
the summer dice will hold more free
in-game events and additional Hut
contracts offering new weapons log and
reward opportunities and there will also
be open trials to check out the vest
been content the upcoming Death Star
expansion will be available to season
pass holders in September it introduces
new ground in space maps weapons star
cards and two heroes one of these
characters is described as larger than
life and someone dice knows players have
been waiting for which means they've
been getting my letters and you'll be
able to play as Jabba the Hutt as a
mostly a mobile slug-like character he
plays my greatest strength and first
person shooters getting shot over and
over again we expect to hear more
information on the death star expansion
during this weekend's Star Wars
Celebration do you know in the Pokemon
games when you lock eyes with another
trainer and then they make a pity
comment and you're engaged in an epic
battle don't try that in real life Fox
12 reports that 21 year old michael
Baker a Forest Grove Oregon was out in
search of Pokemon at 1am this week when
he saw another man maker thought he was
a fellow Pokemon go player so we
approached him this person then
allegedly stabbed Baker in the shoulder
I saw him go by and asked if he was
playing pokemon go he was like what I
guess he wanted a battle because he came
at me with a knife Baker said a
spokesperson for the Forest Grove police
department confirmed to gamespot sister
site cnet that Baker was stabbed in the
shoulder the investigation is ongoing
the spokesperson said adding that there
were several witnesses showcasing the
decision-making skills you'd expect of
somebody making a beer run at one in the
morning Baker said he didn't go to the
hospital right away because he didn't
want to stop playing pokemon go also he
had to pick up some beer and chips Baker
eventually got his wound sewn up with
eight stitches are the other guys back
yet no okay so I guess our other hosts
aren't back yet but you know I'm sure
they're still out hunting Pokemon
they'll probably invite us tomorrow it's
cool I don't mind but for more video
game news check out gamespot com